happy Mother's Day everyone check out
life-of-the-party or breaking in both in
theaters this weekend
instead of giving your mom a rose for
Mother's Day when I booked out all of
the rows of your local movie theater huh
Rose Oh mom
I'm trying to film weekend ticket
[Music]
all areas Melissa McCarthy is added
again in life of the party surprised
with divorce her character chooses to
return to college to complete her degree
/ do all the college things you were
grad slash wish you could relive mom
you're a college girl now
and we gotta make some changes no we
don't know where that's been Oh God my -
the party is for you if you're a fan of
Melissa McCarthy comedies like
bridesmaids spy or the heat or if you
love good old-fashioned college movies
like old school or even Animal House
Melissa McCarthy is hilarious in this
movie but good news she's not the only
funny female comedian life of the party
also stars Gillian Jacobs from community
and Maya Rudolph also from bridesmaids
and Saturday Night Live breaking in is
the breakout thriller of the week the
talented Gabrielle Union plays a
kick-ass mother who is forced to protect
her kids during a home invasion in a
secluded high-tech mansion I hate when
that happens
breaking in is for you if you're into
other intense home invasion thrillers
like panic room or movies about
empowered parents forced to throw down
to save their kids like Liam Neeson's
taken or Jodie Foster's white plan
Gabrielle Union is definitely the reason
to see this movie she's proven she has
moves and bring it on and then she can
hold her own in action scenes and bad
boys too but this role brings it all
together to really showcase her talents
and that is your weekend ticket happy
Mother's Day moms and check back next
week for show dogs the action-adventure
comedy with Will Arnett and in the
comments let us know what's your
favorite mom based movie
[Music]
you